sometimes it's not about what decision
you make just make one and commit to it
self-determination and fate
intentionality and trust i mean
it's always a balance of those two and
that's what keeps life being a
consistent game i can't not
know what the heck would happen if i
didn't take the challenge or find out
that's what will keep me up at night i
think we need to start a new unbranding
campaign
sensei mcconaughey
ladies and gentlemen believe nation i am
super excited to have a special guest
with me the legendary actor and author
of the number one new york times
best-selling book
green lights mr matthew mcconaughey
welcome board man
good to be on board evan how are you sir
i'm great man so listen as i was diving
into your story
there was one thought that kept coming
up over and over and over again
but this man mcconaughey is the
modern-day
texan bruce lee
texan bruce lee the texan bruce lee what
a great combination that is
because you're an actor but
a student a philosopher a teacher
and maybe not the world's greatest
martial artist but willing to step into
the pit
with championship tribal wrestlers
in africa yeah that last part is true
didn't have much to do with martial arts
um um i was thinking you were going with
you know
you've got the texan texans bruce lee
i'm going ooh
he knows when to go east and when to go
west um
when did when when to be forceful when
to go with the force
um and i would say geez that whoever
that guy is i i'd like to be that guy
i'm trying to be that guy
i love it dude i think i think we need
to start a new unbranding campaign
sensei mcconaughey
well you know about another campaign
that took off from reading the book
that has a similar rhyme to it okay
i don't know which one was it
reconnaissance
i i like sensei mcconaughey i think i
think that has some legs to it
uh i dig it and listen why is because
you have this ability to take
viewpoints that i think other people
would see as contradictory like this is
the opposite of this and you say no
this is actually the same thing and you
find that balance between them
and so i'm super pumped to dive into
some of those things today um
yeah first one that i had in mind was
the idea of intentionality versus trust
so yeah you're very intentional in what
you want to do you're intentional to say
no to
to acting gigs that you don't want to
take on you're intentional in writing
green lines and by the way everybody
link in the description below go check
it out but in writing green lines like i
want to write this book off of all my
diaries for the past
couple of decades and even though the
guy who's supposed to help me gets
pulled from the job
i'm still just gonna drive to the desert
hold myself up
have my journals in front of me and i'm
gonna write this thing
right that's intentionality yeah but but
you get there
and there was this line that you said
was just look at what you have and let
it reveal itself
yeah it's like you don't know what
you're going to do and you just trust
that it's going to reveal itself into
what would become
this and this is not a typical book if
you go through it and you read it it's
not something that you would normally
expect
so how do you balance the intentionality
of i need to get this thing done
with the trust of i don't know how it's
going to play out and let it reveal
itself well
you know a new venture i finally i
finally get the courage to grab all of
my diaries and head out to the
desert to place where i'm gonna have
nobody interrupting no thing
interrupting no
no email nothing it's gonna be me and
myself
me stuck with me for the last who i've
been the last 50 years
okay this is exciting this is scary oh
uh
i can't wait i get there i'm very
excited
i'm a little anxious like going into any
new venture and um
i'm starting to tell myself okay we got
to get a plan here we gotta
we gotta get organized uh um again let's
go the western way right let's go
let's go let's go the structure way
let's write the headline first and then
and then write our story towards that
headline and as i'm doing that
it's all fine um but after a few days
i'm like looking
at the what i'm pulling out of the
diaries and
what i thought was going to be more
academic is actually turning out to be
more poetic
and philosophical so i'm like oh
you thought what you the common
denominator of what you've been writing
the sort of the category it would fall
in would be more academic what you've
been writing for the past 36 years
because
but no it's not and that's okay so i
backed off
went made myself cocktail and said look
it doesn't matter what time of day it is
we sleep when we eat when we when we're
hungry we're gonna sleep when we're
tired
we work day or night whatever no rules
starting with
let your diaries tell you what they are
instead of coming in
intentionally saying i think i know what
this needs to be i think i got a hunch
of what this is gonna be
and it turned out to be very different
um it was much more it was much less
academic than i actually thought it was
gonna be it was much more
um folk wisdom it was much more out of
backbone of stories
uh a narrative in it it was more lyrical
it was a little more poetic a little
more
philosophical than i thought it would be
and it was funnier than i thought it was
gonna be and i thought it was gonna be
pretty damn funny
well i think this is where people get
stuck in limbo mode as well
is that they have this intention to go
make this thing but then they don't know
how it's going to happen and they hit
some kind of roadblock and
and so then they they stop trying to
make it perfect trying to have the
perfect plan and the perfect words and
the perfect whatever and then
then you're in limbo for the next 10
years limbo sucks
limbo sucks so so how do you get people
out of the limbo phase look at the last
year and what's continuing into this
year
the world at limbo i don't know the
future
it's not clear it's all hazy we've been
you know with code year we've had a huge
limo year
i mean again it's a combination of these
things uh
intentionality and trust meaning
there's great opportunity right now in
business and
career in in life in this
disruption that we're there's great
opportunity i'm not exactly sure what it
is
i got some hunches i think some of us do
have hunches oh we will be coming to
work from anywhere anytime world
that's what i've had to do over the last
year how was it how did it work for me
what did i prefer about it what can i
not stand about it
how much is we're going to go back to an
old normal versus a new normal
you know that's everyone's gauge in
those different things so do you
find an opportunity now uh which would
be more about almost
um in some ways
intentionally persisting to go i'm gonna
i'm i'm seeking out opportunity and then
when do you go
all right let me let me let me back up a
minute widen my lens and go
on the truss side let me dance with
what's happening
instead of just charging ahead keeping
what i've got to float
or looking for an opportunity with what
was my original goal say before a
pandemic here before limbo hit me
now let me know let me back up the
rhythms of the world have
changed the rhythms of my working in the
world my engaging my relationships with
people
with my business with my faith whatever
it is they've changed things
we could all agree they've been thrown
off off off kilt
so how you know the the trust part is
let me back up and find a new song
let me find a new rhythm to the world
and how i move in it
um that's the trust part that's what i
did when i said
with the book i intentionally said i've
got the stuff i got the courage to come
away now i'm going to write it i know
what it is just achieve
what the headline i've written this
academic headline now go achieve that
well i got there i was like wait wait
wait a minute wait that's the wrong
title to the album
it's a different album than i thought it
was i'm hearing different music than i
thought i was going to hear
i'm reading different things in my
exercise and i thought i was going to
read let me sit back and let this music
play
and let me let it reveal itself to me so
it's all i mean that's
one of the great arts of living right
there self-determination and fate
intentionality and trust i mean
it's always a balance of those two and
that's what keeps life being a
consistent game um
that we never had that we'd never have
figured out
how do you personally balance the dance
to know
when to do one and when to do the other
east or west transitionality
yeah right well
you know let me tell you this whenever
when i was writing this book i
noticed many things in my last 50 years
which again i thought was going to be
almost 100
of write the headline first intention
i'm a great goal setter i write things
down at night
i like to have her list uh
i i jot things down i look at him i head
towards that stake in the sand i have an
idea of the transcendent self i want to
chase and i go
after it i try to take it into life and
start create the intuition turn it into
a habit and put it into action
write the headline first then write the
story towards a headline
but damn i noticed a whole lot of
beautiful things i've crossed in my life
where i just jumped off the cliff and
figured out how to fly on the way down
where it was not intentional where
actually the only intentionality was
getting my ass out of the door with my
proverbial shoes tide
to go say i'm going to find out i don't
know what's coming
i look at it and work in career my
favorite work i've done where when i
dove in going i don't know
what's in the pool but i'm doing the
proverbial but i'm diving in and
it's dark but i'm trusting i'll come up
on the other side
with something that's been my favorite
work because i went into the adventure
uh my favorite trips you talked about
one with the wrestling trip mali
africa those were literally chasing down
dreams but i didn't know what
my answer was i just said i'm gonna go
put myself geographically in the place
that my dream has told me to put myself
and not and not give myself a return
date
that would cause any anticipation or
nerves or anxiety about when am i gonna
go
so i want to take the roof off of how
long it will take i want to be there
open-ended
both those trips took about 22 days solo
journeys
but i didn't know the result but i ended
up finding writing the song along the
way but i didn't know i was writing a
song until it was over
you know where i wrote end up writing it
was a spiritual journey for me having a
wonderful spiritual journey that i
didn't notice
was one until it was in hindsight
so those were times where i jumped off
and just said i'm gonna go find out i
don't know what i don't know what the
heavens out there man but i'm gonna find
out let's go
this to be like water bruce lee well
that's the bruce lee part for sure
at the same time you know so look look
i'm 51 i've got a family of three i've
got i've got a wife my mother's 89 with
us
i have fundamental responsibilities that
are non-negotiable
all right which disallow me from
completely being
bruce lee eastern bruce lee come on go
with the win trust it go with it
wherever it goes
go with the song no i've got my weather
created i've got some
i've got some uh what i call it some
some construction the fundamentals of my
home
are built and some are built and many
are built on a rock
and it's not negotiable for me to leave
those i've got things i've got to take
care of so i cannot
any longer get a whim tonight
and tomorrow morning take a one-way to
molly africa with a backpack
i've got things i got to take care of
here i can prepare to do that
and thankfully i have a wife who nudges
me out the door when she knows i need it
but i can't just do what i used to do
before i had the responsibilities i have
now so i'm not gonna go be foolish with
the responsibilities of things that i've
the gardens i've already created that
i've still gotta tend um in
my life um so
look i'll say this i do like i go
conservative very liberal late
meaning i do like to go the texas way
first right they build the fundamentals
check out the sandbox we want to go play
in what's the what's it look like up
there
where i'm heading let me just check and
see if there's any broken glass in the
sandbox before we get nick and do
backflips in it right
let's rake it let's check it out how
many lanes do i have
on this direction i'm heading let's make
sure i've got you know i love it
rather it be an autobahn eight lanes
with padded walls great it's headed that
direction
now get in and now let's swerve now
let's go liberal lake now let's go
eastern now let's blow with the wind now
let's put the blindfold on and see what
happens now let's dive in
check out create my weather so i can
blow in the wind that was how i prefer
to do it i do like to check out the
horizon first
no guarantees it's all clear but it
looks good okay
all right now let's head into it i love
it now you know you have a special
relationship with the word can't
and i know growing up your your father
would give you a whooping if you said
can't
yeah and can't was a worse word than
swear words
yes mouth washed out with soap for
f-u-c-k and s-h-i-t but you said c-a-n-t
you got the belt
and so it's another one of like what
most people would think even me growing
up i
i now as a 40 year old man still don't
swear because of
growing up but most people would say
that swear words are really bad but kant
is how many times people say can't in a
day so
like flip that tell us why cant is just
such a toxic negative word that um maybe
one of the greatest lessons from your
parents
where there's a value in can and and and
there's an asset in the antonym of can't
that was one of the early words that my
dad let us know
you say that word and now mine he's
telling his children so what i think
what i now know he was in
what he was instilling is is you say
that word you start to believe that word
you think of
something that you that you're having
trouble doing
as oh i can't do it and i go and and and
it's a dirty word that's a that's that
that is a if you believe that heading
out into life once you go out to
negotiate
it on your own um you're not going to
get as much
much as what you want in life when you
are on your own so what i think
that's what that's what dab was
instilling this i remember this lesson
one day i come in we already knew we
weren't supposed to say the word can't
it's saturday morning seven a.m i'm
supposed to go do my chores mow the lawn
we need the
property i'm trying to get the lawnmower
started it won't start
i'm gonna start we'll start won't start
i check the gas everything's good it
won't start
i go inside my dad's in the kitchen
doing something there's a pop
i can't get the lawnmower started he
goes and i saw his molars meat
and i went uh-oh when i saw the mower's
meat i was like oh geez i just said the
bad word oh
look at that and he turned and he looked
at me and i went
ah and he didn't say a word walked by me
lightly grabbed him by the arm we walked
out of the kitchen through the garage
around the back of the house to where
the lawn mower was that i
that was not starting he reaches down
cranks it a couple times it does not
start
i'm standing nearby he leans down fidget
thing finds a hose that maybe was
disconnected anyway presses choke gets a
gas flowing
tries again boom start running lawnmower
right there next to us he walks from the
running lawn mower over to me
about 10 feet away kneels down to my
eight-year-old self puts his hands on my
shoulders looks me in the show looks me
in the eyes and goes
you see buddy you were just having
trouble
bingo yes ah
okay i've even in and it's carried on
in my belief that even when we are
unable to do something
that does not mean we can't we can seek
help we can find an expert
there's a way to get things done so i
think we throw the word i can't out
we've i had i've already had two
sessions this morning and it's not even
past
noon where i am where we've had to go to
the kids you what
you what you what oh i'm having trouble
there we go
we it's just you can have trouble just
don't start believing you can't
and so the antonym of that is you know
um
you actually you you can it's parceled
along with my
disgust with the word unbelievable is
another version of can't
and why i don't like the word
unbelievable at all um
so that's where that's that's where cam
having trouble
yes i'm having trouble fair what do you
need can i help you sure
so you pass the lesson back on to your
kids now but it's a trigger word can't
becomes i'm having trouble
well you think about think about your
persp you know your perspective moving
forward
you know i can't well you stop what
happens when you say i can't your mind
goes to i quit
i'm done i'm not gonna try anymore and
we all know
we raise kids we have we know it on
ourselves there's many things that we
just
can't get it done and mentally let
ourselves off the hook when we're like
actually
yeah actually if i focus on this maybe
if i'm
read the directions you know i mean
whatever that is
maybe if i persist i actually could or
i'm going to find out
until i get to the
place where it is inevitable when you go
no i'm actually unable like me
i'm not gonna i get it i'm five eleven
three quarters
i don't physically have the ability
without help to dunk a basketball
but i can dunk a basketball with some
help maybe i need a trampoline maybe i
need
i don't know you know what i mean i'm
just saying so the idea of uh it's just
a good one
and i think it's good for us as adults i
think it's good for children too just to
go and
and it keeps it it helps with endurance
it helps with resilience
uh it helps with attitude and
understanding and negotiating the world
to get what we want
and hopefully what we want what we need
but yeah it was a good one and and i've
stuck it
we're we're instilling it in our kids as
well as we can
but we've been doing it for years and
trust me already this morning i've had
two sessions you what no
you're what you're what you're what are
you what oh i'm having trouble there we
go
the repetition though the repetition
it's going to come i love it
talk me through how important it is to
get the result versus the effort because
as i hear you tell the stories of i
can't hey your father just
kept going and he was pulling it didn't
work but once he
fixed the machine then it worked and
balance that with your story in
in green lights where you're in africa
you're wrestling michelle
wrestling champion giant tree trunk legs
and the whole community is cheering you
on
not because of how well you were doing
but because that you had the
courage to just get into the right
intelligence yeah to accept the
challenge and step in whether you
whether he just destroyed you or not
they're still cheering you on because
you accepted the challenges say yes
so how does how do you fit i can't into
that is that i can't take him
on or like i can't beat him like how do
you tie the the result
of winning versus the effort of trying
well let me tell you like let me let me
explain that moment
when i've just come off a 14 mile hike
i'm tired
i'm laying down the village two young
village boys
about 18 years old come up and are
japping or yapping at me and i can tell
it's aggressive
and i find out that they're the
they're the wrestlers of the village
they say they are the champion wrestlers
and they're challenging strong white men
named doda which was the name i was
under to wrestling match and i'm
i can hear just in their intonations and
how they're talking
their their voice is a little too
soprano to really mean it
they're kind of yapping and when i say
the east i go
are they talking he's like yes they
don't really mean it because they talk
too much i go oh we have that in america
too if someone's talking too much they
actually don't really mean it sometimes
well the community gathered around
all of a sudden they start screaming why
do they scream
well the same reason the two boys run
because
what steps up is michelle the champion
the real champion of the village
who the kids ran off because they were
saying they were champion and so now
they were embarrassed because the real
champion's going to come there and whoop
their butt
well when he stands over me points at my
heart then points at his heart
and then points over to the right where
there's a big dirt pit
my heart starts beating fast
and in this here i'm like going are you
kidding me no
way but the i can't is coming in the
other ear going
i can't not know what the heck would
happen if i didn't take the challenge or
find out
that's what will keep me up at night so
that immediate sort of
delayed gratification or forethought of
wait a minute if you
don't you will always wonder i can't go
through that i'll be sleepless at night
i'll wake up wondering what story would
have come from that at least
so by the time i'm going through that
i'm already standing up in front of the
guy pointing my heart into his then move
so that's where the icant comes in there
um
i would look i i
my version of can't in many different
scenarios comes from
i can't i i i can't handle not knowing
i can't handle not finding out i i i
don't
want to not find out
the not knowing will drive me crazy the
wondering what if
damn it it was right there i knew it it
was right there
why didn't you do that what was i'm
gonna be embarrassed to failure
i'm gonna be ashamed of
losing i mean those are already two
things that when i just say them
if i hear somebody else say that to me
i'm reaching out going no dude feel more
no it'll be a shame screw up find out
find out and lose find out and fail
rather than sit back at one or go i'm
not sure
you know the great penny allen my mentor
of 19 years
when i came out of that unbranding phase
of two years without working
and started turning down big money i
remember her saying
f the bucks go for the experience man
now mind you i was in it i was i was
already financially set enough where i
was able to do that my rent was paid but
i chose creative work to go do where i
was like i don't
don't even show me the number i'm going
after the experience
how do you how do you make that split
second decision is it just because
you've done it so many times
because you so many people they live in
regret
right and you're going to go back home
in a few days okay
you're in the moment you've got this one
chance tomorrow michelle's not going to
take you on
how do you decide like i'm doing it well
you know i mean a lot of
a lot of masks going on through through
eyes ears nose senses i'm feeling
i've been in the country long enough i'm
i'm doing the math right now
that this big guy wants to wrestle me
i've seen
how wrestling in this part of africa i
don't really see anybody
coming away dead um so that's going off
that mass going
i don't think you're gonna die if you
lose bad i've seen
people walk away i've seen them bow at
each other a la bruce lee i've seen them
hug after wrestling matches so i'm going
oh they they have a healthy look at the
sport
i've got a feeling that this is just
part of the sport now i don't know if
you can hit i don't know if you can bite
gouge whatever but
i'm thinking these things that this
could be some good old wholesome
if i lose i'm just going to come away
with a you know
i don't think anything should be i don't
think i'm going to come away with the
broken bone
i think i may come away very sore and
bloody which i did
but i didn't but but i've got a my
measurement
uh uh the the challenge was not vicious
like i'm going to we weren't we we
weren't battling over
the one woman in the village or battling
over food for the year
you know what i mean so this math in a
much shorter time than i just explained
to you is
coming through my mind at the same time
the community is now got about 80 strong
and they're jumping and cheering
and i'm like well i mean i've gotta i
mean are you kidding me this is gonna
get to be this is the night's
entertainment and then i'm like god
and you know what i'm also going through
my head i'm a pretty decent wrestler i
had two older brothers men i grew up
have to defend myself
you know i'd like to maybe test my texas
skills over here in the middle of africa
and find out
you know all these things this math is
going on
and the next thing i know like i said
i'm now standing up and accepted the
challenge and moving towards the dirt
pit
um to go take on the challenge um
look you know if if if if the guy in
that situation
pulls out a knife i'm
looking going ah and i'm starting to
back up the other way going nah
let's go with our birthday suits what
god gave us what did no no we don't need
a weapon here no no hang on
so i mean it's it's looking pretty
manual
it's looking it's looking like a real
sport it's looking like i don't know if
i'm about to get my
my ass kicked you know but let's go find
out
um this and then also i have this look
and this is part of me that's a ham
i know in the back of my mind i've got
another little chimney cricket going
at the even if you get your ass kicked
at the very least it'll be a great story
[Laughter]
so i will say this i do say yes to
taking a certain risk
just because i'm going well i don't know
man but
damn that might be a great story to tell
and what's impressive is how fast like
all of that
compressed into seven seconds to say yes
right
you don't have a lot of time sitting
there in front of this guy and i think
that's what
most people are missing is that they do
the math and it takes
them three days to do it and then they
regret not saying yes
well and yeah i mean you know
there's an under um this one hadn't been
i don't
not many people talk about this one and
i don't talk about it enough i think
in the in the book i write about
sometimes it's not about what decision
you make just make one and commit to it
i think there's actually more value to
unpacking that
than even i'm giving it credit for
because
we you read your a versus b what do i do
what do i do what do i do what i do what
and as you know boom
that window of opportunity shuts or you
sit there and
what i do i'm not sure i'm going to do
this what do this a day goes by a week
goes by a month goes by
that girl that guy they're gone they
moved to another town
that job opening went to someone else
that purge
the wow what i do what i do what i do a
year goes by i got friends
that decades gone by a lifetime's going
by because they're still away in these
two things
and i think a lot of times it's like
just choose one and jump the
repercussions
aren't near as bad as we think they are
even if you choose the wrong one
if we commit to one of the choices if
it's the wrong one
it will reveal itself to be the wrong
one more quickly and clearly
if we jump and don't just dangle our toe
in it
if we give it justice going i'm going to
try and make this work i'm going
wholehearted
it'll reveal itself to be the right or
wrong choice if it's the right one if
it's a 50 50 chance
bam i'm so damn glad i jumped and took
the opportunity when it came i hit i hit
the gap i took it
if it's the wrong one we're like oh whoa
this is not this is not right
well now we found out quickly enough to
pull the parachute and abort and back
out or
we jump in hard enough something brand
new reveals itself
because the options are compounding with
whatever choice we make
make one and find out and what's the
big deal that's another percent what's
the big deal if it's a wrong choice
we got more time than we think time is
on our side more than we give it credit
for
what's the big deal that people go well
i don't want to do it because i want to
waste that time in my life i don't know
if that's the wrong thing
and you end up saying that for weeks
months years
decades when you look up you're like
going oh i'm still
measuring which one i should do and now
i'm in my 40s now i'm in my 50s now i'm
in my sig
whoa just try it it's the worst it can
happen it's the wrong decision so what
reset come on back i at least i found
out
so i think it's i think that's a good
one for us all to remember
we're going through this rodeo of life
sometimes it's not really
which decision that's most important
and dissecting them into limbo
just or dissecting them into immobility
dissecting them into paralysis
just pick one go try one try it out
what's the worst thing you order the
wrong thing on the menu damn it
i knew i should order that other thing
well now you know so next time you come
back now
you eliminated one now you know what to
order
do you get frustrated with yourself for
just
being in limbo and then force yourself
out of it by just picking one
sure i i i suffer from being hasty for
sure
and i have to remind myself about the
sensei bruce lee side wait a minute as
my buddy richard link later says sensei
mcconaughey
how's my brother the religious link
later said he helped me out with the
great poem a couple years ago a few
years ago
the spider weights in his web first pray
to come
that's the bruce lee side that's the
eastern
side because i am i do like to be doing
i need to
accomplish to feel significance
i can get addicted to accomplish i can
get addicted to
i sleep better at night when i can check
off those things that i had on my list
that day
did it did it did it did it well i gotta
watch that because
that can too much of that can suppress
creativity
it can suppress sort of like well no
wait a minute there's a larger there's
larger movements going on here it's not
just about
the trouble of checking off the little
numbers on your list each day there's
what's the larger moves the moves that
will that you could
the things you could do the choices you
could make right now that have like a
20-year 30-year 40-year 50-year infinite
sort of
uh um uh resolution
in them you know there so it's not just
about checking things off
what's the creative overall life change
move you might want to take so
yeah i have to i have to watch myself
from getting hasty because i love to
check things off the list i have to
watch myself often just make a choice
do it um and i go through
you know i i do spend time with big
decisions
a lot of times to contradict what i was
saying earlier
um i'll i'll live in a decision go
look i do with rolls all right i'm doing
it
i'm doing it camilla we're doing it it's
in mauritius we're going it'll be three
months we'll be five months there
i'm diving in my head i'm thinking in my
future as if i'm doing this job i'm
making this choice
now i sit in that for 10 days
do i measure in that next 10 days did i
am i writing about it all the time am i
seeing the world through that
character's lens or
is the family getting excited about
going is my relationship with the
director and the producer is going well
man is am i
more feverish about wanting to do it now
than i was even when i said i was gonna
or why did i just wake up with a
nightmare
oh i don't trust that guy i don't trust
that i'm not sure if this is for me is
it waking me up at night to not do it
now vice versa
i'll then go after that 10 days
not doing it family not doing it after
you not doing it
i don't tell the producers i just live
in that place that i'm not doing
now what wakes me up at night
the idea of oh my god i can't lose that
role i can't lose that experience i've
got to do it
so i'll make it's a mental trick it's a
mental game i'll play with myself to
live in the yes and live in the know and
a lot of times
as we all know that reveals which one we
should do it's a it's a it's an extreme
version
of why so often we don't we're not sure
what to do but if we just have someone
like i'll go to camilla or she'll come
to me
and just say it out loud all of a sudden
we answer ourselves
it's a version of keeping a diary it's a
way to get objective about your decision
you're writing to yourself but putting
your thought into the written word
is already making a socratic dialogue
where you're where you're becoming
objective about your subjective feelings
so all of a sudden you sit there and you
go oh well now i know what i want to do
because i've brought it up
or i've spoken it out to someone and
actually i came to you asking for advice
but you don't even
tell me anymore because i just figured
it out because i asked you it happens
all the time
um so that's an extreme version of what
i'll do sometimes just go 10 days
in the yes i'm choosing this and 10 days
in the no i'm not and see what wakes me
up at night
see how turned on i am all day see i'll
see if i go 10 days ago i haven't really
thought about i said yes to that project
mentally but i haven't even thought
about it again well that's a good sign
that maybe it's not the right decision
for me
because i'm not getting the fever you
know or i woke up with a nightmare about
doing that because i don't trust this
situ this pedigree
around me in the situation or that they
the script's not good they say we'll
work on it but
i know what that means they just want to
get you in the job and no one's really
working on the script
well maybe that's a good it's the good
fear and the bad fear
you know there's good fear and then
there's bad fear that we got to listen
to those spider senses that tell us this
ain't the right situation
this group of people this decision is
not going to give me more roi
in my future okay so
again all this talk it's it's it's an
art man i mean
and we're all it's the game we're all
playing
it's the canvas we're all we're all
painting on and i don't have a
rule and i intentionally i'm happy i
don't have a rule i'm happy there's not
a rule
because it's up for every each one of us
to personally go
what's my dance here with that and
it always seems to be a balance of of
those and i think those are you started
off it is all paradox i don't think any
of those are contradictions
i think admitting that you contradict
yourself inherently makes it a paradox
i love it now let's talk about one of
your hardest decisions which i think was
what you call the lung the long
unbranding phase
where you go from being top of your game
all those romantic companies people
throwing millions and millions at you
and you say no no more romantic comedies
i'm going to go
i want i want drama i want more serious
roles and you go 20 months
without having real work even though
they keep increasing the price and
throwing more millions at you it's like
no
no no no and they finally say wow he's
serious okay no more romantic comedies
are him
what i find the most interesting though
about that story or at least that period
in your time
in your life was when you were
considering maybe not being an actor
anymore it's like hey maybe this isn't
for me anymore if it's 20 months and
still no
decent gigs the jobs that you considered
going to
what i found in my research was at least
great for teacher
high school uh football coach uh
animal guide or or uh
wildlife guide wilderness guide
orchestra conductor
and first off it speaks to your
diversity and just how crazy different
all those things are in adventure field
but what's the commonality between all
of them
including green lights right it's
teaching
those are all teaching roles you're
teaching creators
you're teaching football students you're
teaching music professionals you're
teaching people about the wildlife
you're teaching
you know your life lessons here in green
lights there's this that's why i like
sensei mcconaughey because because
there's this teaching
vibe that has that has been in you for i
guess a long time
and it's i think super curious that all
of the jobs you looked at were all
in the teaching realm um i never never
thought of it that way thank you for
simplifying that
um and finding that common denominator
yeah i like i mean the first two
i have a real affection and i'm drawn to
youth because and i'm learning how
important it is now i've got a 12
11 and an eight year old uh
and i'm learning what effect my teaching
can have on them i'm learning
as we all do as parents what stuff
you're like no
that's just dna they are that forget
don't even fight that battle that's just
who
they are we can shepherd them uh but i'm
learning what effect i can have what
effect i
do not have i'm learning how to teach
the three of them in three different
ways
um our foundation deals with high school
students in title one for me that's like
oh it's the last chance to get
young men and women before they are
free men and women in the world where
they have to negotiate on their own
where the consequences may not be a
demerit
you know or or going to principal's
office because of this
the fangs are bigger in the world if you
if you screw up
or if you stay on a certain path so
we're trying to get them on the right
path that inspires me
um i also
inherently think i'll probably learn
more when i teach better
i'm also inherently intrigued with
ways of teaching you know
who you talking to part of the reason
why i love telling probably stories
or who you talking to i have to i have
to teach my
each one of my kids differently than the
other one now i'll treat you all fairly
i'm not going to treat you the same
if i'm pitching a movie i'm in if i'm
telling a story i tell it differently to
my eight-year-old then i tell it to my
wife
you know i'll i'll tell differently to
my mom who's 89
then i'll tell it to you it's the same
story but
i've got to rearrange it and how i tell
it
and there's i think there's an art and
storytelling um
i've never really thought about that
those things had a common denominator of
having a teaching quality i mean my mom
was a teacher for 39 years
outlaw teacher never had her teaching
certificate fibbed her way all the way
through it
successfully um
i think i have a gift with being able to
inspire i'm really big on personal
choice i don't know
i i i'm not it doesn't really interest
me about what it
what's a big collective
policy or law that changes
i i'm i love the power of choice
and and i think the earlier that
we can understand that power is ours
you know i i i i
we should go we should follow a minister
so that will teach us to
the power of being ministers of
ourselves you know what i mean we should
we should follow leaders that teach us
that yes
you you know you know
leaders can give us vision but they
can't do it for us
they more than have trouble doing it for
us they actually cannot do it
for us um so you know i
um that still
inspires me and that's inspired me for
what i'm thinking about what my next
however many years in this life
are gonna be the book was you know i've
done movies um
and that's entertainment hopefully some
enlightenment maybe some education
the book is now translated people are
going no i'm seeing myself in this this
isn't
just a story about you this is a story
about me this is a story about humanity
i'm getting some things out of this
mcconnell hey thanks
i'm going wow look at this reciprocation
okay
um it's translating i'm a teacher but
i'm also a learner so maybe the two
there
are the paradox too like i said earlier
i think i think maybe the reason i lean
into teaching is that's where i learned
the most
and that's why i also feel the most
measurable gratification of seeing
somebody get something
oh oh i see
say i get it say
yes sir yeah no ma'am yes ma'am no man
please and thank you
out of respect but also because i'm
gonna get more of what i want in life
oh cool um i i go back to the to
it it's got to be personal in in sort of
all of my
approaches to life and teachings is that
it's it's it's it's
up to you um you the power of choice
and self-determination i'm big on at the
same time
you know back to bruce lee sensei
i don't know has it all been written
already you know what i mean it's all a
mystery moving forward it's all the
science looking back
um again those two as well would not be
contradictions but
well and i mean also looking at green
lights it's not just a memoir there's
teaching in here
through the storytelling through the
sticky notes you know through all the
things that you throw in here
it's it's a it's a teaching guide just
using you
as the kind of hero of the stories we go
through
my follow-up question that was if you
have this teaching streak
that's i guess been in you for a while
the acting stuff
do you see that as also teaching
and maybe a reason to move towards more
serious films that you want people to
get
something out of the film beyond just
entertainment and that maybe
led to the long on branding or is it no
acting is just
one thing i do and then i my personal
thing is about teaching
my hunch right now is that's the second
um but i would say
let me say this though where there is a
consistency you know
a lot of the comments about this book
are going oh my gosh you were so they
used the word vulnerable oh my gosh you
showed all the words and i'm like
yeah and they're like but wasn't that
like oh my god why'd you do that i
would've been so scared i was like man
that was like
freedom like yeah and in my own life and
around my own family we
laugh at our warts we bring them up we
shine lights on them
where we don't get we've been taught
don't get embarrassed about your
screw-ups let's shine a light on them
laugh out and move right on and carry on
that's
part of who we are actually preferably
and i don't think that's just for say me
and my immediate family
who i was around i think that's for for
most of us and i think that's a good
thing for us all to learn
those things we cover up society tells
us to cover up so much
well those whatever they are whether
they're warts or demons or whatever
they're gonna come out and be
revealed sometime in the future so why
not just
uncover it and go here it is here's who
i am doing the best i can i screwed up i
failed over here i tried this one but it
didn't work out
uh my buggy sorry um whatever those
things
are live a little more transparently and
again
in this if we do that individually we're
also more
forgiving and resilient when peop with
with ourselves and others we take we
start taking more responsibility because
we're not
fearful of the failure maybe we we start
to
have more generosity which all all those
things lead to more freedom i do believe
and that's not just for me i think that
is
for all of us um so the characters
though if you look at the last 12 years
of work who've i played
very island
men on an island men who had their own
personal
sort of ethos of how they were going
through the word they weren't
characters that were following the
manners and graces of the
of the the mean of the times they were
on the outskirts they're a bit outsiders
um i love their independence i love
their self-sufficient
i love their will to survive i love
their will
to uh um there's certain inherent sense
of optimism of i'm gonna make this work
i'll die for it
well if you can find a character if i
can find a character that's like no i'm
what i want i'll i'm willing to die for
whoa
that's power now boy if we can find that
kind of thing in life
those non-negotiable things we're like
non-negotiable
now if we're on page 62
and i'm fighting the non-negotiable and
i'm gonna
i'm gonna die for it and i'm well there
we go i'm out i make it to page 62.
that's as far as movie goes with me
you know what i mean or how do i
overcome that
i like finding characters that that run
into great resistance
for which to have the opportunity to
overcome um
i look for that in my own life
sometimes i think we have to i know i do
have to create resistance maybe where
there's not
resistance because i'm looking around
going kind of skating on easy street
right now
and again another balance i talk about
in the book the art of running downhill
well sometimes when things are going
right and the breeze is at your back
damn it
enjoy it because the uphill's coming
but other times you can look and go
without feeling the breeze behind my
back
i'm only catching all green lights in my
life now because i'm really not taking
risks
well maybe that's the time to go i got
to create some resistance i got to
reframe i got i got to make it a little
bit more difficult on myself so i can
dig deeper
and figure something out uh about what i
want to do that's going to be the right
kind of risk
or going to make me feel more alive or
turn me on
um yeah so there's a
similarity from those characters and
into
the the life that i'm trying to live
for sure um and and and me
showing through the book
what people call vulnerabilities i'm
like boy that was actual
freedom to be able to share those and i
also understand objectively that i'm in
a position
as you know a famous movie star whatever
you would call me celebrity some people
go
no i know we all go through that but i
didn't think you would share that or i
didn't think you would go through that
and i'm like no this
all this stuff i'm sharing that was was
truth long before i was ever
an actor celebrity we have rights as as
mammals as people as citizens long
before
we have rights as a celebrity or success
in our lives and our jobs and our career
and so that's what i think i was trying
to uncover so how much of
who i am is because is responsible for
why i've had success in my life and how
much am i successful because
and how much of my responsible or or
who i am because of my success you know
those
those two those i would say that a lot
of my success has been
because of who i've worked
to be before i was ever who you know me
to be you know i mean who you see me in
the world uh
to be um i love it my last question is
about
heroes and i know you're famous for
saying you know your hero is who you're
going to be in 10 years so
51 year old matthew is here with 61 year
old matthew and then at 61 and 70
71 and so on um and you're always trying
to basically achieve the unachievable
and that's that's the chase and the
climb and you want to grow forever my
question is as you're going through
all your journals to create green lights
there's some cool stuff in here there's
like messages from when you're 12 years
old
in your journal that you that you're
writing down i'm wondering how was
what did you uncover in your previous
journals where younger matthew
is your hero today right something you
had to relearn again like i already knew
that when i was 14 and i'm learning it
again at 50.
yeah well
you know i i there are things that i
pulled off
got away with in my youth some of the
stories are in the book some are not
that i still wake up having nightmares
with today but i only wake up having
night wares with them today because now
i know better
and if i didn't know then what i knew
now
i'm i'm afraid i would have been able to
pull a lot of those things off
the ignorance is blisting there were
things i pulled off because my
my ignorance that i look back i'm like
going dude you are so
lucky how did you you almost got killed
and i'm not talking about the wrestling
match i'm talking about some other
things and some of the things that are
in the book i'm like you
how did the percentage of you making out
of that situation alive if you went back
today
are so low and we're so low then
but because of your ignorance because of
your singular belief and that you could
pull this off without and and you didn't
you didn't get nervous at the situation
where most people would get nervous
or you went with the flow or you pulled
the bruce lee sensei
time you know um at the right moment
to get out of the jam i try to keep
as my friend uh mark says
and the hero that i have back then is
keep the beginner's mind
keep that uh because it's great to have
knowledge
it's great to have context at the same
time
we see it with kids our kids all the
time their lack of context their lack of
not just to blatantly go do it because
it's just i didn't even think why think
about it don't need to explain it just
do it i don't know i ate the cake
because i wanted it but sweet it's right
there it's eat it
something beautiful about that more than
something beautiful about there's
something inherently
uh true about that that that
as we grow older we should not put away
is going to oh that's just youth
oh that's that's just back when you're
you that's just the thrill of you no we
could still
have those things and that's going with
full intuition and saying like i'm don't
give a damn about the consequences
let me bring this up because i do think
there is a
i found a consistency in people in the
youth year revolutionary right
30s you start to go some of the stuff
mom and dad taught me was right
start to take a little responsibility 40
she kind of customized him yeah you know
what maybe i'm becoming a parent maybe
i'm saying yep yep yep i see how i work
in the world i'm responsible for others
and myself
somewhere in the 60s it seems like a lot
of people go
back to being the revolutionary i don't
know if it's the fact
that you go oh subconsciously i'm on the
back end of my life so
what the hell's it all matter and why do
i give a damn about guns my mother is a
great example of that
she's 89 part of the reason she's so her
memory's so sharp and she's so alive
she's the least considerate person i
know
and it's why it's what's so lovable
about her
because she's 89 i asked her mom don't
you go to bed
at night with anything on your mind that
you regret things you want to do better
she goes oh honey every single night i
go to bed and i make a mental list of
the things that i wish i could do better
the things i regret that i did that day
she says but you know what matthew i
said what she goes when i wake up in the
morning
i forgot them all i mean she's just like
she's an example of the value of denial
if you really commit to it and she's not
a shallow person
she can talk with sages and presidents
and senseis across the across the board
but she's just a bulldog who had to
survive
and and through her life and goes
through going up i'm not gonna
and when she does things that are
inconsiderate you kind it's kind of
what's lovable about her
because she's just like yep i did it and
i'll do it again
you know she's not trying to harm but
she'll just do things you're like
did you take any consideration of what
the cause and effect that would be to
the rest of the family
well tried to pull it off okay you
busted me got me now what
turn the page what's next so she just
she's a perpetual motion
force um that is very much like a child
in a way before they know or understand
consequences of cause and effect or
understand context things like that
so that beginner's mind which my mother
has and i find that a lot of people
start to get it as they get
older in age maybe after their kids are
out of the house or after they're like
what does it matter you know what i'm
just going to do my own thing i'm about
to die or something maybe that's
in mine i don't know but there's a call
back there's a book and it seems to me
that a lot of life bookings that people
start off as that revolutionary
beginner's mind
get conscious get aware take
responsibilities create their life and
then all of a sudden
the the end go back to what's it all
matter let's rock
i don't care the consequences what i
love is you
start with a point take us down some
story and adventure
that we almost get lost on and then just
before we lose it you bring us back to
what the point is and remind us why
we're doing it
and guys if you want more of that check
it out
the book is called green lights we'll
link it up down in the description below
sensei matthew mcconaughey thank you for
joining us man appreciate the time
evan quite enjoyed it could go on for
hours i remember that i'm gonna keep
thinking about this common diameter of
me wanting to be a teacher
thank you all right much love appreciate
you man appreciate it
if you want to see the recent one-on-one
i did with tony robbins check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there the quality of
your life has nothing to do with how
much money you have on any beautiful
children you have how many people love
you
the quality of your life is where you
live emotionally this is the time to
retool
it's a time for you to say where's the
world now where do i think it's going